[music playing]
JASON SILVA: I think that
I was a restless kid,
a very creative but restless
kid that wanted answers.
So I was afflicted by
the bug of question
and questioning everything.
And that inquiry sent me
to beautiful spaces of mind
and imagination, but also
sent me to very dark spaces,
whether it was thinking
about mortality
or thinking about impermanence
and all these horrible things.
I felt that my way of dealing
with pushing away the darkness
was by losing myself in
beautiful things, so ineffable,
transcendent experiences,
the rhapsody of poetry,
or the high you get from a
beautiful film when it sucks
you into its wonderland, or
the orgasmic ecstasy of falling
in love, ineffability, magical
transience spaces of mind that
were characterized by
feelings of selflessness
and timelessness.
So losing yourself
essentially became my escape
from existential dread.
And I felt like it
was my responsibility
to find a way of clothing
these numinous experiences.
That's where the
verbosity, the desire
to bring back these experiences
and share them with others
has come from.
So in the same way that a
musician might find inspiration
and then he composes a song
to describe that [inaudible]
experience, or the way that a
poet might have some inspired
rhapsody with a
lover and then he
comes back and then
writes a few words
that touch a billion people.
People say some things just
can't be put into words.
I disagree.
I think that's a
form of laziness.
I think that what's
magical about words
is that they can be used
to describe everything.
I really do believe that.
And so the more complex,
sublime, beautiful,
and ineffable an
experience, the more
I want to try and make a piece
of content about what that is.
It's me in a way having
a creative battle
against ineffability.
It's like the universe is
saying you cannot explain me.
And I'm like, oh, yes, I can.
So that's kind of my thing.
It's a control issue for sure.